Hey, super interesting story for you.
Yesterday, a campaign staffer for Michael
Bloomberg's campaign, uh, showed up at my
house in Massachusetts, just canvassing the
neighborhood.
And the reason that this is interesting is
that
I was just telling you two days ago that although
it's not likely that Michael Bloomberg is
going to get the nomination, his best strategy
would be to forget about the first four primaries
and just pour money and resources into the
super Tuesday States.
Super Tuesday of course is the day, the first
day where you have a bunch of primaries in
one day and this March 3rd is super Tuesday
and this election cycle, we will be having
the following primaries on that day.
Alabama, Arkansas, California, Colorado, um,
uh, Maine, Massachusetts, Minnesota, North
Carolina, Oklahoma, Tennessee, Texas, Utah,
Vermont and Virginia.
So Massachusetts is on that list.
It's a super Tuesday state.
And um, I spoke to the guy for a little while.
He didn't say Bloomberg is ignoring the first
four primary States, but he did say that based
on what he has seen, there's not much talk
about Bloomberg having a big ground game in
Iowa, New Hampshire, Nevada and South Carolina.
But that he sees that the focus seems to be
States like Massachusetts and other super
Tuesday States.
Now I'm also getting reports that Michael
Bloomberg is funneling money.
I mean just pouring buckets and buckets of
money into YouTube ads, particularly for people
who are accessing YouTube from those super
Tuesday States.
So it actually does seem like the Bloomberg
strategy that I sort of, uh, uh, mentioned
on Monday is exactly the calculation that
Michael Bloomberg has made.
And the reality is it's so far, uh, since
I talked about Michael Bloomberg two days
ago, he's up another half of a point.
Uh, Bloomberg now is averaging eight nationally.
Bloomberg is starting to build a lead on Pete
boot edge edge, uh, and, and pushing more
solidly into fourth place.
So what you have to understand is that if
Bloomberg's trajectory continues by the time
of super Tuesday, especially if Elizabeth
Warren keeps losing momentum and doesn't get
any wins in the first four States, Bloomberg
could be tied for third place by the time
super Tuesday arrives.
I hate money in politics.
I think it's corrosive.
I think it's toxic.
I want to see the system absolutely upended,
destroyed and taken apart.
But the way that Michael Bloomberg is using
the system to build support seems strategically
sound and compare.
You know, there've been all these candidates
that have just been hanging around for months
and months and months.
Bloomberg announces his campaign late, very
late and for two months just pours money into
YouTube ads and TV ads and he passes a lot
of people who have been running for a very
long time.
Look at, you know, tool.
See Gabbert has been running for so long.
Bloomberg rockets, pastor Tom Stire, [inaudible],
Tom Stier running a buy my way in sort of
campaign.
Bloomberg coming in, spending more money rocketing
past Tom Stier.
Amy Klobuchar has been around for a while.
She even was endorsed by the New York times
along with Elizabeth Warren Bloomberg rockets
past Amy Klobuchar.
Andrew Yang has fallen behind a Michael Bloomberg
and now Michael Bloomberg is more than a point
ahead of booed edge edge in the national polling.
So again, the strategy I outlined would be
let Bernie and Biden fight out those first
few States because remember, if Bernie wins
them or if Biden wins them or if they split
them, the margins of victory are going to
end up with Biden and Bernie having a similar
number of delegates after those first four
primaries.
When you get to super Tuesday, it's still
going to be wide open.
Because remember, you get delegates in these
first four primaries.
As long as you get 15% of the vote, you get
some delegates.
So if Bernie beats Biden by 10 in every state
of those first four, Bernie will be winning
going into super Tuesday.
But it'll be a lead that could disappear instantly
depending on super Tuesday results.
The opposite is true if, if, uh, whether Biden
or Bernie, when you are going to see them
very close, a number of delegates going into
super Tuesday.
So what Bloomberg appears to be doing is go
right to super Tuesday, pour money in to those
States.
Maybe he can get up to 15 in a few of those.
And again, if he keeps gaining on Elizabeth
Warren, he can justify staying in well beyond
super Tuesday.
You're almost guaranteed to see the likes
of Stier and tool C and maybe even yang and
or [inaudible] start to drop out as they get
delegates.
Remember, if you don't get 15% in a primary,
you get zero delegates, zero not if you get
10% you don't get 10% of the delegates, you
get none.
So you're going to see candidates start to
drop out.
And this Michael Bloomberg strategy could
actually work to keep him in.
Okay?
Now let me do the normal caveats.
I've got five angry emails when I did this
Monday saying, David, you support Bloomberg.
Now I am not supporting Bloomberg.
I don't believe Bloomberg is going to be the
nominee.
But if you said to me, David, you've got to
bet 100 bucks right now.
Do you bet 100 bucks on Bloomberg or Buddha
judge being the nominee?
I say Bloomberg.
If you say, David, take a bet.
Is it going to be Bloomberg or Amy Klobuchar?
I'm bending on Bloomberg and if you look at
the betting numbers on predict wise and look
at how people are placing bets on who they
believe will be the nominees.
Bloomberg's in third, it's Bernie followed
by Biden and then it's Bloomberg that the
money thinks will be the most likely candidates,
uh, most likely candidate to be the nominee
after Bernie and Biden.
That definitely tells us something.
He's adopting the exact strategy we talked
about on Monday and he is gaining support
as a result.
He may even be at 9% by the time the first
votes are cast on Monday.
We will continue
to follow it.